[Music]
foreign
yeah thanks a lot definitely chat GPT is
one of the best buzzwords if you want to
apply for this kind of conference I'm so
excited to see what's next year is going
to bring but let's just focus on large
language models for those 30 or 40
minutes and see uh whether they are
really useful or is it still just a toy
that we could play a bit with but
nothing really else because uh We've we
have all seen
that large language models including
chat gbt were not only used by people
working in Tech such as you but also but
by the traditional media some
journalists so that's definitely a topic
that will be hot in the upcoming months
and there are probably more and more uh
use cases for it but we also need to be
be sure that there are some limits and
that there are some ways of how to
overcome and overcome them but the main
issue that we have with uh with chat
gpt-like models is the fact that they
produce some responses which may sound
reasonable at the first glance but it
turns to be they turn to be uh
counterfactual
I tried with asking chat GPT it is
charged GPT version 3 because it is
becoming more and more
uh complicated to find like a good
example that would be completely against
the common knowledge I just asked for
the previous capital of Germany and for
those who are not German that may sound
like a reasonable response right
Frankfurt could have been a previous
capital of German money why not but it
turns out to be uh to be false
because Bond was actually the the
previous capital of uh West Germany at
least because Germany was divided into
West and East part so that's basically
like a simple case where at in which
charge GPT failed to answer correctly to
to given prompt but that's actually the
the fact that I was able to get from
Google just by providing a simple query
so this is basically something that our
model should have been exposed to during
the training phase because that's how
those large language models are being
trained but this is also something that
it couldn't remember properly for some
reasons and this is
Germany
yeah but that should be also like the
correct answer to to my prompt
but okay uh I could accept that it may
be just simply wrong but it will be way
better if it could just simply provide
me the the answer that I don't know or
I'm not sure I do not have that
information
and this is something that we call
hallucination and Hallucination is a
response of large language model which
is not uh justified by the by the data
that it was trained on so this is
basically a case that we really need to
avoid but we have no idea of how to do
that yet we need to focus a bit on the
training process because that's the
reason why those large language models
tend to confabulate and this is
basically a screenshot from a great talk
by Andrei karpati this is a state of GPT
that has been released recently and that
describes the whole process of training
gpt-like models so the the first part
the pre-training is something that is
like the most important piece here
because it's being done on some huge
corpora of language textual data that
has been scraped from internet
uh well people used to say that we are
trying those models on whole internet
but that's not exactly the case because
we are used they are using some sort of
publicly available data sets like common
crow this presentation also links to
some some data sets which has been uh
used to try at least some of those and
basically as you may see they are using
trillions of of words uh to train the
pre-premodel that is being used as a
base for some further fine tuning and
that's one of the reasons we are taking
the data of a low quality uh well my mom
used to say that I should be reading
books instead of looking at my computer
and reading the internet and she was
right about that and probably we should
do the same for training models if we
really care about the the quality of the
data that we put into uh well any single
book at least those better ones let's
say may go through uh should go through
the some sort of Freeview process so we
can expect that the information that is
being put inside and a particular book
should be at least confirmed by somebody
else not only the offer uh so that's
that would be definitely a better data
set to train some general language
General usage language models because
they would rely on some uh factual
information not something that somebody
decided to put into the inter into the
internet but that's actually something
that we need to do because it's just way
easier
and this is basically
a network that is being trained to
predict the next token but nothing
really else this base model is then
being used in some further fine tuning
so then we are using less data but of a
higher quality and that's actually where
it learns some uh to to to really work
for some for some specific cases we have
the supervised fine-tuning phase then
our model can be also fine-tuned even
further with
some additional model in that process
like we can create a reward modeling
system that would be ranking the the
responses returned by the system
actually this is pretty complicated
process but this this presentation uh is
uh available so if you are interested in
more details uh please just uh watch it
carefully because that that shares a lot
of a lot of cool things about the
training process of of this kind of
models but there are actually like uh
three different models that we could
deploy actually you can create a large
language model based on this publicly
available huge amount of data and it
will be also working pretty well for
some cases but if you put garbage in you
can expect garbage out
and that's exactly uh what happens with
large language models uh the answers
that are provided based on our prompts
or queries may sound reasonable but they
are just predicting some next tokens
based on the on the prompt and the rules
or knowledge they they learned while
during the training phase so that's
exactly the the whole objective for the
training and that's what those networks
also do during the inference
there are two components which are
included into the prediction the first
one uh is the internal state of such a
network that was uh uh that was created
during the training phase and that
surely includes some rules but those
might be like grammar or language rules
in general
also including some let's say common
knowledge but there is no easy way of
how to uh how to check what the model uh
learns during this during this journey
that's actually one of the uh one of the
issues because there is no way to
validate that it really really was
trained properly and can uh can predict
not only the next token but also factual
statements
and there is also a context that we put
into the uh into the model so whenever
you send a prompt whenever you query
this kind of system uh this prompt is
being used in order to provide those
tokens as a response and that includes
uh The Prompt that you put inside but if
you use an interface like chat TPT it
also uh involves putting some previous
conversation into the context but that
happens under the hood you are not
really aware of that
but that's something that has to be done
in order to include uh the context of
the whole conversation not only the
latest prompt
and the other thing that uh
is a cause of of hallucinations in large
language models is the fact that they
see the world as if it was frozen
that's basically because the the
training process is is fairly similar to
any different training of neural
networks we need to collect some data
and we need to cut it off at some point
just to start the training and that
happened for chat GPT uh the card of
time for Chad DBT it was like September
2021.
so if you ask some questions about uh
anything that happens after uh it may be
simply struggle with that and right now
Chad dpd already responds with some
uh like uh answers that I I have this I
have the data set up to September 2021
and if you are asking for the future I
cannot uh tell you that but that was
like fine-tuned after this this preview
phase actually this this models uh
guides a lot just because many people
started sending those prompts and they
were just able to catch up with all the
possible mistakes it might be might be
doing
um and this is completely different if
we compare to humans that's why I do not
like calling that AI at all this is like
another machine Learning System maybe
just a more sophisticated one but still
uh we cannot I I don't want to use the
term AI to to call A system that is uh
trying to predict the next token that's
fairly uh
doesn't seem to be justified by by the
fact what I understand as as
intelligence so contrary to humans those
large language models do not learn
continuously you might be interacting
with them for a while sending some
different prompts into them
and it may seem to remember those facts
but if you just refresh the browser
refresh the page in your browser you
won't be able to retrieve the
information that you provided before and
that's that's in fact because uh those
models are not being trained in real
time that's actually a process that
requires lots of computational power you
would need to come back to the slide
about the training process but but
that's basically a matter of uh days in
the best case and it cannot be done by
providing all the products because
people may be interacting with with
those systems in a way that we would
never want the model to remember and
that's something that we we cannot
expect from from those models but I I
just feel that we have some high
expectations I really recommend reading
the article mentioned here it's all
about uh our high expectations that we
all have for those large language models
but they are actually that's exactly the
same thing they are trying to predict
the next token so they may be really
good at some language tasks but not
necessarily be used as an oracle that we
ask and a question and expect to to
receive a correct answer
a really great article but there is also
one lesson to be learned from that uh we
cannot expect that that this kind of
models to be providing us factual
answers but we can use them in order to
solve some language tasks because that's
in fact something that they were trained
for and those language tasks include
rephrasing or summarization
and that's already something that may
help us build some some really cool
application based on the large language
models
and this is one of the one of the
possible solutions to to avoid
hallucination
in order to
have in order to avoid them we can think
about extending the context and
rephrasing the task that we want this
kind of system to solve so it's no
longer a
knowledge uh knowledge knowledge task
knowledge created task but rather a
language task that they should be
hopefully able to solve because that's
something that already happened during
the fine tuning process some better
quality data was used to to solve this
kind of this kind of uh this kind of
task so that's basically what we could
expect to be working pretty well
and expanding the context with some data
requires us to possess this information
already so you may ask what's what's the
reason for including this data if I
already have the answer but that's in
fact not something that we uh we need to
have we only need to have some sort of
reliable knowledge base and a way of how
to extract some relevant data to be put
into our prompt uh to extend the context
if I ask the following question and put
just a simple par a single paragraph
from Wikipedia
I just asked the same question this is
at the end of my problem and put a
single that's actually the first
paragraph of the whole article about
Germany I I think
then the task becomes way easier because
right now the model can simply
use the provided information to somehow
summarize and answer my question by
extracting a single piece of information
that I wanted it to
but there are some limits of course I
cannot put like whole Wikipedia into
into every single prompt some say it
should be possible to put even your
whole knowledge whole knowledge base if
you work in a small company but those
models uh and I might be wrong here
because I couldn't find a reliable
source for that information but I just
found found some uh some comments on
some forms like there is a limit of
tokens and this is the number of tokens
you can provide into a single prompt of
chat GPT like model so that means uh
it's not like a a single token doesn't
mean a single word so it's even less if
you count towards and it's quite hard to
predict how many words you can put
because that's language dependent
that basically means that we not only
need to provide some uh some relevant
information into our prompts but we also
need to like extract only those uh those
pieces which might be relevant and
that's a challenge that we are all we
were trying to solve for ages so far
it's a problem of search and how to how
to handle that in those new
circumstances
uh there are some attempts to extend
those context Windows anthropic model uh
climbs to support
hundreds thousand context context
windows
which seem to be uh quite quite huge but
if you work in a in any company that has
a no slack some Confluence or a
different uh or notion or a different
system that you used to to to like uh
share the knowledge share the internal
knowledge and how to of your company
then if you just calculate all those
texts uh combine all the text together
and calculate the length of them it will
simply turn out to be not enough and
there are some other issues that we have
with those uh huge context windows for
example uh
if we just increase the the context uh
window we can actually pass some more
data so this is pretty useful but we
still need to know what to put inside a
single prompt so we are not solving the
problem of of searching we we still need
to find those relevant documents and put
put them inside our prompt we can just
include some more examples instead of
putting just three way we can maybe put
I don't know 100 but still there is a
limit which is obviously a little bit
higher
um that's that's another point we need
to know what to put inside uh
another problem that we cannot really
expect our knowledge base to be limited
even to that high amount of possible
documents and this is pretty damn
expensive you want to use those those
models uh you usually pay based on on
token that you used in in your prompts
so if you for every single query you
would be putting uh like a hundred
thousand uh tokens
uh then every single call to that API
would cost you about a dollar if I
remember that properly so that's
basically not something that you could
afford in the long term if you support
every single user query on your on your
system using other lamps but that also
takes a lot of time passing those data
into the into the prompts and sending in
over some Communication channel like
HTTP definitely need more time than just
passing I don't know 100 100 characters
or even a thousand
so there is a solution that that many
people claim to be right now the only
one of how to overcome those those
problems and this is retrieval
argumented language models uh this is
basically an extension of large language
models we are still using them but uh we
support this uh prompt formulation with
putting some additional context uh in an
automated way so for that we need to
have a reliable search system and in
this case that has to be a semantic
search because keyword based search
doesn't apply that well
I but I will just try to describe it
further on so what I mean when I speak
about semantic search basically we are
using deep neural models which are
capable of encoding any type of data
into some fixed dimensional vectors and
those vectors have this great
ability to be close to each other if the
they represent a similar concept so if
you just put two different pieces of
text by describing the same idea you may
expect that the vectors produced by such
a neural network will be close to each
other in some way we usually calculate
this distance based on cosine distance
or dot product but there are a variety
of options there's a variety of options
available
but ninety percent of the times we are
using uh we are using cosine distance so
this is basically
basically each so semantic search is all
about
comparing the vectors but comparing the
vectors on on a really high scale
because your knowledge base may be built
with thousands of documents and if you
want to if you want to do it you need to
have a have a proper tooling so
basically semantic search is really
important uh to add to create those
retrieval based ritual augmented
language models and semantic search is
the capability of ability of of deep
neural networks to encode different
texts describing the same idea to the
vector spares space in which those
vectors will be close to each other as
is in that example stripe blue search
made from cotton is exactly the same
thing like Maritime cotton made Maritime
shirt so that's basically the uh
the idea that that somebody had in mind
while creating this query was exactly
the same uh they just described it
differently and we can use that for our
advantage because that can already
capture some uh different queries even
draw some some words were not used in
our in our documents
so this is basically it the semantic
search in opposite in opposite to
keyword based search can already handle
some synonyms and multi- many languages
at the same time there are some
pre-trained models available also uh
provided as apis by open AI or here but
there are plenty of plenty of companies
offering this kind of this kind of
systems so you don't necessarily need to
train your own models but you can always
fine tune the existing ones so they
reflect your knowledge in a better way
um and in order to serve Vector surge in
production you need to use some sort of
vector database and quadrant is one of
uh one of the possible solutions it's
written in Rust and mostly focuses on on
the performance uh there are various
ways of how to interact with it
you can run it on a single machine for
the development purposes but you can
also seamlessly switch to Cluster if you
want to and there are also some
additional filtering filters possible to
be applied on top of vector search so
let's say you are looking for a piece of
clove similar to the one which is
presented on an image but in addition to
that you also want it to be honest in a
specific color or from a specific fabric
that can be also done that cannot be
easily captured by the vectors so you
need some additional filters to be also
appliable
and this is how the interaction with
large language models look like without
the retrieval argumentation which we
just send a prompt and this is directly
sent into the large language models and
it's up to you if you want to put some
additional contacts or if you do not
have any any idea of what should be put
into it and you may expect on the large
language model to be to be just
hallucinating if you do not provide it
but if we just decide to extend the
system to include this retrieval phase
we need another two component so we need
an embedding model that will be
converting our prompts our queries into
the vector representation so you are
free to choose whatever works for you
this there is a huge room for
experiments and you need a knowledge
base and Vector database such as
quadrant may play a role of this
knowledge base because it may be
indexing the vectors for your documents
and those vectors might be then used to
extract some relevant documents uh while
whenever a new prompt is being sent so
then when our user sends a prompt it has
been enriched with some relevant
information which has been sent along
with the original query into the large
language model this is actually a
pipeline that has been implemented in
many different libraries that are
becoming more and more popular nowadays
but you can also do it on your own
that's not that fancy
and not that complicated to be to be
implemented
so how do you build this knowledge base
this is actually uh something that
requires some some processes some
offline processes so you can index all
the documents that you have in your
organization or the documents that you
would like to use and those might
include some private data that by any
means couldn't be included into the into
the training phase even the the first
round
we divide some longer documents into
chunks and those chunks are being
vectorized by our our embedding models
and those vectors are eventually being
indexed in the knowledge base along with
the texts that were used to to produce
the vectors So then whenever we receive
a prompt we can ask for some relevant
candidate documents and include them
into the prompt and we typically set a
limit that we want okay
closes documents K most relevant
documents which are available for our
prompt
but it doesn't seem to be solving all
the issues that we have with uh with
hallucinations and large language models
um there is still something else that we
need to do and this is all about prompt
engineering I really like the term uh we
are right now trying to find the people
who are capable of talking to our
oracles that we created before that
that's exactly what uh what may happen
if you just ask a really simple question
uh to chat GPT I asked for some
countries which names start with r and
this is a response I expect that five
countries and the thing to know there
are only three countries uh on the whole
world which name starts with letter r
but because I asked for five uh model uh
wanted to
just just make me happy
because it was trained to reward uh
proper answers and that was like the
task I wanted five answers so it
provided five
and that that's an issue because uh I
may be just thinking that this is a
correct answer if I just include it in
my pipelines if I would be directly
using those uh those responses for some
further processing I would just uh be
relying on some fake information however
if I just allow the model to uh
just provide me some some
like a shorter list if there are not
enough not enough uh data not enough
information it changes its mind and
tries to to replace those uh obviously
long entries like Qatar in the previous
slide with some republics which is
right to some extent but still there are
plenty of republics around the world and
that's not exactly something I wanted it
to produce
so I also need to exclude those
republics I need to know how the model
behaves in some specific cases and I
just need to make sure that it won't be
making that mistake and finally if I
formulate my prompt in that way uh it is
able to produce me a list of results
which are not only fulfilling my
criteria like I wanted five but they are
also uh true and that's something that
we still need to uh still need to learn
how to provide the prompt in order to to
be able to retrieve only factual
information from our models so prompt
engineering uh is is hard I have to say
I was trying to to figure out some
different ways and
there are some cases in which you you
you would be expecting the model to
answer properly to your to your queries
but it's not the case we still need to
experiment a little bit and if you just
change your large language model let's
say you were dealing with llms for a
while you were experimenting with charge
GPT and then you switch to I don't know
llama then it turns out that you need to
learn that from from the very beginning
because the the prompts have to be
formulated differently that happens if
you just experiment with different
different models but first of all we
need to allow our models to not provide
the answer if they do not know it and
that's exactly what we need to put into
the prompt because they were rewarded to
provide the answer so there is no reason
why they would be answering that they
don't know it and that's something that
we need to include but it also needs to
be sure that that the reasoning scheme
of our models is is uh is correct so
that's something that that's a strategy
that is quite common nowadays asking for
a reasoning scheme and if you include
this kind of this kind of request into
your prompt you would be able to track
step by step how the how the model was
was uh retrieving that that information
at least you may expect it to to be to
be returning that information because it
might be still hallucinating on the
reasoning scheme so but that's not
something that we can we can avoid in in
all the cases uh but the most important
important thing is to turn the knowledge
uh knowledge based task knowledge
oriented prompt into a language task so
summarization or rephrasing of the of
the documents seem to be a way of how to
overcome those problems and uh
it's also great to to expect the model
to include that in our prompt to expect
the model to return the sources if you
just provide n documents into the into
the context then you may simply simply
expect it to to return I don't know some
sort of identifiers or a number of the
document that it used to produce the
answer
but there are still lots of challenges
how to keep our knowledge base up to
date because because uh this is not
fixed and and many events happen every
single day so we need to make sure that
we have a process that can back up the
knowledge base and and provide the
relevant information as as soon as it
has to be provided
um we all also need to uh have some
other other constraints being applied I
applied on top of vector search if you
ask it for the president of US and the
cutoff was uh was done in September 2021
then it might be just simply wrong but
even though if you have a database and
you have all the information about the
past presidents of us if you just put
all the all those data into the into the
prompt it might be just choosing either
of them so we need to have some
additional constraints applying on top
and that strongly depends on the use
case uh one thing to note quality
assurance with with uh llms it's not
that easy
there is like another process that
people try to solve with another model
being included in that whole pipeline so
a different model is just verifying the
the answers of of the large language
models but still we do not have any any
way of how to do that properly that's
really tough and when it comes to tools
which entire can be used for that the
most popular one nowadays is link chain
but if you have worked with flank chain
then you you may know that they are
trying to be really up to date with all
the recent updates in large language
models but it comes with a cost it's
quite hard to maintain a long-term
application because of the release cycle
is so fast that they try to release a
new version every single day and if you
work with open source you know that that
should require some more effort to like
test the things probably and just make
sure that they do not break anything
that is already working based on those
libraries but High stack and llama index
seem to be better Alternatives they are
more mature projects so to say and they
try to keep the release cycle at some at
some
in a proper way and some some high level
so so of of quality so that's definitely
something I would recommend using but if
you have any questions I hope we still
have few minutes for them if not then
this QR code will direct to my LinkedIn
profile please just feel free to drop a
message anytime and here are my socials
thank you
so thanks so much for your presentation
it was a bit daunting to get here but uh
you did very very well so
I think there would be some questions
who
asked some questions for Lucas about
this
seems to be all clear
ah
um
thanks for the presentation and for
overcoming the challenges
um so my question is around have you
ever tried or heard of this option of
doing the retrieval afterwards so
basically I'm asking a rather vague
question I get a response back that you
know hopefully has some truth in it and
then just search for those truths and
verify if they actually are in our
retrieval system well I haven't tried it
yet that sounds like something that that
might be possibly one of the ways of how
to like uh make sure that the quality of
the responses is is cool
um I'm not really sure I haven't I
haven't used that so far but that's a
cool idea I would definitely try it out
okay because I just want to follow up a
little bit
um because
my problem is that probably my questions
would be too vague to actually search in
the database in the first place so I
wanted to be expanded first before I
search yeah that may work I would
definitely love to hear more about the
use case you are trying to solve because
if the queries are that limited then
then that might be great to just
understand maybe you just need a
different retrieval process under the
hood as well if if the questions are I
don't know the semantic search works
great with retrieval augmentation
language models just because those those
queries which are being used are more on
the long tail side so so they are pretty
long they may include some keywords but
they come from the natural language so
so the semantic search works way better
than the keyword based search but maybe
you can think about having some hybrid
or even a keyword based search if that
works in a specific case it really
depends on the use case but I would love
to hear more about what you are trying
to solve
cool thank you very much
foreign
[Music]